let's read a car is traveling see meters
behind a truck both traveling at a
constant speed of capital v m/s the road
widens l meters ahead of the truck and
there's an overtaking man the car
accelerates at a uniform rate so it's
exactly alongside the truck at the
beginning of the overtaking way okay so
pause for a moment what's the situation
this is a real situation in fact I was
doing this the other day when I Drive
your home from Wollongong a lot of high
speed roads right if they're going
through like a arm like a lot very
mountainous area something like that
even though it's high speed so you think
multiple lanes because you're going
through this hard territory when they
were creating the road they only had
space for a single lane so therefore
you're stuck behind this truck okay now
you're going at the same velocity and
you're maintaining this gap and then you
see the sign that tells you okay I can
overtake suit right so at a particular
instant of time you decide right I'm
going to accelerate so as soon as this
lead opens up then I can just simply
slide in and I can overtake it off I go
so at some point this car is going to
move up to the overtaking Lane it's
going to accelerate so it can be faster
and get up to that in the same amount of
time sorry that the truck takes to get
there right so for example suppose um
the truck is ten seconds away from
getting to the overtaking click OK and
you're like all right I'm going to use
the same ten seconds I'm going to hit
the peril so in that 10 seconds I cover
this amount of ground so as soon as we
get there we're both together and then I
can overtake does that make sense do you
understand physically wrong time
okay so there is the picture and then
they had you this part a what is the
acceleration of the car okay so this is
the question right now like I said I
think this question is particularly
cruel I guess it's fine it's an
intervention part because in case you do
it clues at all okay or at least not
many obvious ones when I looked at this
question the first time I was like man
wet when we even begin now the first
thing you should know when you say what
is the acceleration of car you know
you're heading for a number it's just
going to be a number how do I know that
go back to the questions when you have a
look at the question which sentence
isn't it's the the last sentence it says
the car accelerates at a uniform rate
okay so for example we know gravity it
accelerates objects at a uniform rate
towards the center of gravity okay so
it's not like you're accelerating really
hard when you take your foot off he just
puts is from the accelerator at a
uniform rate to catch up this distance
okay so I know this is going to be a
number of some kind but another the
second element that makes is challenging
is I don't know what any of the numbers
are right i get handed a whole bunch of
constants but it's all algebra okay so
somehow I've got to combine all of this
and what I'm going to get at the other
end I expect is going to be in terms of
all of that okay so if this is what I've
got the acceleration of the car by
definition I know that acceleration is
going to be something related to
velocity right what is acceleration in
terms of from velocity how do i get to
acceleration
I'm going to differentiate with respect
to time okay good now I putting down
acceleration of the car because later on
I'm going to have to talk about the
truck as well so I'm just trying to
distinguish between it so the
acceleration of the car is DV on dt so
long as I'm talking about the car okay
we'll talk about the truck and its
acceleration a little bit later on okay
okay so this is fine what do I do with
this like just feet for a second I don't
have many like it's a bit like rock
climbing and you're at a certain point
you let you look around you like what
can i grab onto okay you are very little
options what could I possibly do with
this ok so I can think to myself all
right I have other expressions for
acceleration like this is not the only
one I can go DV on DD half p squared on
DX I can go second derivative all that
kind of thing just place it's not going
to be a good direction to go in though
for two reasons number one you know I
don't have anything here in terms of
like relative to the displacement what
the velocity of what the acceleration
should be unlike say simple harmonic
version that is the classical place
where i do-- philosophy acceleration in
terms of displacement here it's not way
oh there are faster parts of road and
slower parts of road ok so that's not
going to be very helpful to me even
though it was one of the options that I
could consider what else could I
possibly do with this life is that a yes
ok so i could think about the truck I
will have to think about the truck in a
second but before I can do that I'm
nowhere near the truck at the moment I'm
still just thinking about the car and
anything I do with the truck is still
not going to connect to what I know
about the car cuz I don't know anything
about the car rear
except for that so here's what I'm going
to put to you when you have a look at
the situation over here what's been
handed to you all i know is stuff about
the velocity at a particular time right
namely at time 0 when I just taken a
snap shot okay it's worth pointing out
as soon as you pass time 0 this is still
going to be capital be right but this
will no longer be right why not because
there's acceleration acting on this so
it's going to change instantly okay so
at x 0 x 0 I know what the velocity of
the Claridge right so how do i get to
using those facts from here what am I
going to need aren't I going to need the
velocity of the car with respect to time
like this is a photo at time 0 right
this is my snapshot frozen in time at
time 0 right so I've got velocities and
I've got a time so therefore I've got to
get out from here I'm gonna need to
integrate our time do you see where why
I'm like what options oh my god I'll
clearly got to get to something to get
over there integration is the answer
okay now keep in mind this is a number
this is a number so I'm just going to
integrate post both sides we just back
to t does that make sense um to make up
a subject because it's you know good too
greedy i'm going to say the velocity of
the car ease okay tell me what happens
this when i integrate with respect to
time
I get that thing it's a constant
remember times time and there's no
boundaries or anything like that so now
I'm gonna write that down now that's I
think that's a capital C now I know
ahead of time unlike you but you could
get us I know ahead of time I'm gonna
have to integrate a few more times okay
there's this inclusive that you're going
to need to know that because um you know
I'm pretty far away from where I'm gonna
have to do a lot more work you so as a
result going to call this C 1 rather
just ridiculously and I'm going to say
yeah that's my constant of integration
okay so far so good right now what was
the point what I choose that what does
this for the ladder you do yeah awesome
okay so this is the velocity of the car
that guy over there so I'm going to say
when T equals zero right the velocity of
the car is actually equal to capital v
whatever have that happens to be capital
fee fraud lesson big so you can tell
from the other be on there so yeah you
could also make
yeah I could put some knuckle put some
tails or so with that whatever you'd
like okay I'm by the way this is just
another reason to call V something even
if there was there other object in there
I've attempted to say if they've given
me capital V in there something like
that I'll say little video of whatever
what via partic will be a point or
whatever just so I don't confuse them
because capital be a little case V you
get it all right so you can see it's
pretty straightforward here is it
because x 0 eliminates this term right
so therefore capital v that's just going
to be equal to the constant does that
make sense so I'm just going to sort of
pull this all together I'm going to say
well this is just going to be a website
this is a subscript R times T a cask
plus my initial velocity makes sense ok
pause for a moment what about some
progress because we know we've used some
piece of information in the question now
I have to think again well what will my
next step we integrated we found out
what the constant was what else could I
go how else could i use some information
that's given to me in the question
you